[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
number 65 we believe we have a lot of
new people joining us today and so we're
going to have to figure out
how to intermingle and get the people
who know how we think
uh on board and get the people who
haven't experienced much yet
onto the same page if you are new there
are
drinks and snacks on the back wall
anthogens are
in the freezer actually in the freezer
yeah the freezer moved itself
no no it's it's over that way um all
right so
uh in order to get us onto the same page
we are going to have to introduce some
uh some concepts that we use here pretty
regularly
and we're going to give you a little
thought experiment and we will return to
it
later in the podcast so we want you to
think about this question
you walk into a house there's a gun on
the table
you pick it up put it to your head pull
the trigger and it goes click
was your behavior safe all right we will
come back to that and you will see the
relevance of it in the context of our
discussion uh
of virology vaccines etc
okay um top of the show i thought we
were gonna just do a few logistics so
let's just
get those out of the way here um we're
thrilled to have the new viewers that uh
we we know we've picked up some from our
bill maher um experience last night
which was wonderful
and one of the things we want to do is
thank uh bill and the whole
real time team uh for for the
opportunity
so for those who have not been here
before and
for those listening you'll have to skip
you'll have to switch venues in order to
make this happen
we do a we do this live stream once a
week and we take a 15-minute break or so
after an hour hour and a half sometimes
it goes longer and then we come back and
do a live q a
and the questions come from you through
super chat at this point we're working
on a different platform but at this
point it's through super chat
and so if you put super chat questions
into the queue
now we have we will see them we never
get to all the questions we make no
uh promises that we get to them all and
then
uh questions that you ask in the second
hour uh we
we also prioritize in the order in which
they come in so if you're interested
in that stick around and if you're
interested in asking us questions
go for it and if you are interested in a
more
intimate q a we actually do once a month
a private q a
for members of my patreon the questions
have all been asked for this at this
point but it's tomorrow
at 11am pacific and so if you are
interested
in uh in getting uh even more
uh from us on a smaller platform where
it's intimate enough that we can
actually watch the chat and
sometimes engage with it go to my
patreon heather heing
and uh and and join there so that's
that's logistics um you gave the
the teaser you're gonna give and um
let's just let's just launch right in
then all right so
um like i said gratitude uh to bill
maher
and the whole and the whole team there
um i'd also like to offer an apology
um why exactly did i not answer his
question
i know why you didn't answer this
question you do and you could answer
this you know
we'll talk about this just a little bit
so um bill asked me a few times
uh if i wouldn't be more comfortable
taking the astrazeneca vaccine
than either of them already vaccines and
the fact is he knows the answer to this
because
we ourselves have discussed this on i
think it was episode 58 an episode that
we devoted to
largely to talking about the different
vaccines and and
um what the various risks of them were
i didn't respond directly either
either or any of the times i'm not sure
if he asked me two or three times
and here's why so you know the fact is
yes the answer is
yes i would uh prefer to take the
astroxenic vaccine to either the mrna
vaccines that are currently on
on the market
why not because astrazeneca is a
traditional vaccine
it's not but it has a more traditional a
more established
uh delivery mechanism than the mrna
vaccines do
so what that means is it's not a
traditional it's not a traditional
vaccine it does not have an attenuated
um actual virus associated with it right
it's actually a dna vaccine and the mrna
vaccines are obviously rna vaccines
what it has though is an adenovirus
associated with it which is its
delivery vehicle and and there are
a number of gene therapies that have
used adenoviruses
in the past um there have be it's been
fewer
and more recently that they've been
begun to be used
uh in vaccines there's an ebola vaccine
that's beginning to use it we have a
visit from one of our podcasts you guys
may see shortly
um so the adenovirus delivery mechanism
is somewhat new
but adenoviruses have been part
of the human selective experience our
evolutionary environment for presumably
millions of years
whereas the way that the mrna vaccines
get
into you and the cells is they're coded
in what are called lipid nanoparticles
lnps and so you'll sometimes see them
called mrna-lnp vaccines
and um and those are brand new
to the human evolutionary environment we
just we simply have no history with them
and they might work they might be
awesome where like
everyone who makes any sense is praying
that they are hoping that they are
thinking these mrna vaccines might be
the future
of vaccine technology because one of the
things they have going for them is their
very rapid development possibilities as
we saw with these two
but um because the lnps the
lipidanoparticles are
brand new to human to
the human evolutionary environment we
just can't know yet and so the risk
seems
higher so that's why i didn't answer
your question directly
bill and i apologize for it but yes i
prefer the astrazeneca vaccine
all right so this actually brings us
back to the thought experiment
great and we will link the two up here
so you recall the thought experiment is
you walk into a building there's a gun
on the table
you pick it up put it to your head pull
the trigger and it goes click
now was your behavior safe no
obviously not that's an incredibly
reckless thing to do were you
harmed no you weren't harmed so when we
say that something is unsafe we
are talking we are including the
question of
uncertainty about harms that may come
from something
and so the question about the various
vaccines
comes down to harms we know about
because they have shown up
in the phase three trials
and harms that are emerging in what's uh
referred to as phase four which is where
we are now where
a large population is being vaccinated
and we're tracking
events that may or may not be related to
those vaccines
but what we don't know is anything about
what happens three years down the road
five years down the road
there may be nothing there may be
something and
frankly it could go either way
so the point is there's a lot to say
knowing nothing about the long-term
implications of these things
would you bet that a vaccine that is
built
out of a viral delivery mechanism that
is similar to viruses that human beings
have been dealing with
for probably as you say millions of
years
or would you go with something where the
delivery mechanism is entirely novel we
have no evolutionary history
with it and so no information about how
the body deals with it now it could be
and there are reasons i could make the
argument why
the mrna vaccines stand a chance of
being safer
in the long run they don't interact with
the nucleus
a lot is going to come down to
differences in the cell nucleus right
so the mrna is delivered by these lipid
nanoparticles into the cytoplasm of the
cell where the ribosomes then translated
into
spike protein which then shows up to the
immune system effectively it gets
displayed on the surface of the
cells in which the vaccine has entered
and the immune system recognizes it as
foreign which is how vaccines work
go on i have one more thing to say about
this okay um so
it is possible that the
bypassing the nucleus has some benefits
it is essentially certain that there
will be
different affinity for different cell
types between the different vaccines and
that may have a lot to say about what
risks do and do not exist
down down the road from here but the
basic point is we are stuck in the
present
with no information about the long-term
impacts of any of these vaccines
we have some basis to guess on the adino
virus
vaccines we have no basis to guess for
the mrna vaccines and so given that if
you had to pick
what would you do this is a relatively
simple question it's basic precautionary
principle right you prefer the
technology or solution that's been
around for longer
all else being equal and you know
there's a ton not equal here but
insofar as we can tease away all the
other variables
there are some clear ways in which the
astrazeneca vaccine
has a more established history its
elements have a more established history
in
the human body right and so if you think
now back to this little thought
experiment and the conclusion that
putting a gun to your head and pulling
the trigger
is definitely unsafe but not necessarily
harmful
therefore safety is about risk then the
question is well what is the risk
now the harms could go the other way for
there's so much complexity here that
they're
they're it's very easy we could put
together a dozen scenarios in which
the actual harm that we would know about
10 years 20 years down the road
would go the other way if it shows up at
all so the problem is it's very hard to
get
all of that nuance into a very tight
discussion in the context of something
like
uh um conversations yeah um
so i guess actually one more thing as
long as we're talking once again about
vaccines uh which is not
mostly where we're gonna we're gonna
spend time today um
it occurred to me actually when we were
down in l.i before we went on
real time last night um you know you and
i are both reading
up some more on some of the literature
that's out there and
you know what something that many people
will have heard is that both the phis
and the moderna vaccines need to be
stored at extremely low temperatures
and uh most people will not have stopped
to consider why that might be
in part maybe in in entirety at least in
large part it's because rna is very
very susceptible to decay and that you
can basically stall the decay out by
keeping it in you know it's such low
temperatures that it that it can't
but not only is it susceptible to decay
but once it gets into the um the space
between the cells
in the body you have ribonucleases all
over this all over the place that are
just
waiting primed to destroy rna and so
this the lipid nanoparticle
coding the vaccine is basically a way
to sneak the rna past the inter inter
cellular space into the cells
and um what what all of that means one
of the implications i think and i don't
think i've seen this anywhere else
is that if there is an error in
um in transportation
in storage and taking too long after
you've taken out of the freezer
and gotten it into your arm it is
likely actually i would think that these
vaccines actually
lose efficacy and so you are going to
get something close to a
a binary situation of this vaccine is
either
as effective as it can be and it might
even this might mean that it's actually
the our mrna vaccines are actually
really close to 100 effective
because what you have sometimes is a
failure to keep the vaccine cold enough
such that the rna is already completely
degraded by the time it gets into you
such that it's not
effective at all and so what you might
expect with the mrna vaccines this is a
prediction i'm making
is extremely high variance actually that
you don't have that you will be less
likely
to have um some protection within an
individual
rather you would have like this worked
because the vaccine did what it was
supposed to because it was kept at the
storage
in the storage way that it was required
to
or it wasn't and therefore it was just
getting a placebo
effectively well so i don't see any
reason
to expect a binary i agree with your
prediction
about the variance but in effect
there's some threshold we're shooting
for ideally with a virus you want to see
cellular immunity emerge that is to say
t cells that are responsive
in this case to the spike protein that
is being
encoded by the mrnas that we're
delivering to the cells
you want to see t cells that react to it
that would tend to give you a good
lasting
immunity which is of course the
objective of the vaccine and so there's
a question about
how much of how much of the mrna has to
actually survive to get into cytoplasm
to be displayed to the immune system
to get that response there will be
individual variation there will be
individual variation
for reasons that probably have to do
with variation in individual immune
systems there's also going to be a
certain amount of luck which
cells actually uh get reached by this
you know this uh slurry that's going to
be
injected into people it's going to hit
some cells and it's going to enter them
and how well it is displayed to the
immune system will matter
i also wonder how this interacts
with prior exposure to covit right
so the fact that this spike protein is
something that some immune systems will
have seen and some immune systems will
not have seen
raises questions so anyway i would
expect
a lot of variance and um the
degradation basically if you know just
simple chemistry tells us that if
the low temperatures are necessary in
order to keep these molecules
viable in order that they make it into
the cells
that those that have been kept out of
the freezer too long
and we've heard multiple stories now of
uh you know
what's the word uh some
group of vials is warming up and
vaccines are delivered to people so they
don't go bad but you would imagine that
there would be intermediate cases and
what will those look like and how will
we recognize them uh
in in a data set yeah now in this case i
would
i would not imagine um that as they
warmed up that they would become
dangerous they're just going to become
not effective uh i agree
first pass i'd guess the same but i'd
love to know and uh
you know hopefully hopefully what
happens is they
the um stray mrnas do just get uh
chewed up in the normal course of the um
the
interstitial space being being cleared
so um
for those of you new here our producers
our 16 year old son zach
zach can you show my screen do we have
that capability at this point
cool uh so i just want to um read one
paragraph this is a paper in
um actually this is a news article in
the journal nature biotechnology which
is one of the nature group
journals from the end of november 2020
which was at that point a perspective
imagining looking forward and saying
what are the vaccines that are likely to
be out there and how do they compare
what are the risks
this is actually an excellent paper and
i'll put it in the show notes
but i just want to read one paragraph
from it which i've highlighted here we
go
still much about the vaccine's efficacy
and safety
and here she's talking about the mrna
vaccines in particular
still much about the vaccine's efficacy
and safety biological details that could
shape the course of the vaccine's impact
on containing the pandemic
remain unknown quote personally i'm
waiting for further data concerning
t-cell responses and duration of the
antibodies says stanley plotkin a
pioneering vaccinologist
and former pharmaceutical executive who
now consults for vaccine manufacturers
and while acknowledging that the data
report data are quote very encouraging
plotkin is reserving judgment on the
mrna vaccines until more results become
available from late stage trials of the
many other experimental vaccines
now moving their way through clinical
development later in this news article
i believe it's him who says by the end
of next year meaning at that point by
the end of 2021
we should have enough data to actually
compare
both you know efficacy and safety at
least through you know a year-ish
um of the various the various vaccine
platforms uh that people are now getting
throughout the world
and you know he as everyone should be is
very much looking forward to
seeing what those data look like yeah i
think um it's
important we've already seen some uh
changes of course
uh for example um cautions about
pregnant uh women not getting vaccines
that uh yeah although on that one yep
um so the the
who and the cdc seem to be in
disagreement they were
and now they've both they've both gone
back to the party line they're both
saying
there's no reason to think the vaccines
should
uh should harm pregnant women now as far
as i know
they haven't those trials don't exist
they're just sort of
saying again we don't think it's going
to be harmful
i would be i would be very cautious yeah
i was pregnant
about getting anywhere near a very newly
developed vaccine
yeah i agree and you know it cuts both
ways uh covet is liable to be
uh consequential for pregnancy so you
know we've got to be even more careful
about lockdown and
and masks and social distancing yeah
yeah so we are not we are in a very
tough puzzle effectively we are all
guinea pigs in a couple of experiments
running
in parallel one having to do with
vaccines the other having to do
with this novel virus and it is very
difficult to juggle the
competing hazards and there are clearly
short-term very
large hazards that come with coming down
with covid
and then we have to compare that to all
of the unknowns over in vaccine space
and uh it's not an enviable position we
find ourselves in
yeah no it's really not so um
we've got to do at the top of the hour
just a mention of where we're hoping to
go
i think maybe is now is a good segue to
talk a bit about consensus science
and then we'll talk a bit about some of
the um
interesting emerging work on the impact
of diet
on covet outcomes and maybe just finish
with a little marine segment talk a
little about tuna maybe and sea stars
which we've promised the sea stars thing
just just a little true anecdote about
ceased it's not an anecdote
a deep phylogenetic history about sea
stars yes
that some people may find interesting to
our sea star enthusiast fans
uh we will not disappoint you today we
will we will get to are we definitely
getting there
i believe we are getting to this okay
now that you've said that all right i
have to we have no choice i have no
choice
okay so consensus science let's do it
all right um
so let us distinguish first between
two kinds of scientific consensus
um on the one hand we have scientific
consensus
that surround things like whether the
um the living creatures of the earth are
the result of a
darwinian evolutionary process
there is a consensus around this now
those of us
who are directly in this field disagree
over some of the details about how that
might work but there is no substantial
disagreement about whether or not
a fundamentally darwinian paradigm
explains the existence and diversity of
those creatures
now it is always because it's scientific
open
to some revolutionary discovery that
would lead us to understand that we had
gotten it wrong
it could be something like were we to
discover that we were in a simulation
and that the simulator started with all
of those creatures
finished and the fossils were
integrated into the simulator in order
for us you know to see what we would
think about it or something like that or
to ensure that we
came to a particular conclusion okay
well that would upend darwinism but
nobody spends their time worried about
this because what we have is a universe
that appears to be real
and the overwhelming evidence of uh of a
darwinian explanation for life
likewise the earth goes around the sun
hiv
causes aids these are plate tectonics
plate tectonics these are places where
we can legitimately say
something about settled science no
science is
so settled that it couldn't be unsettled
by a later discovery but
you don't spend your time worrying about
it but one thing
that is notable about all of these
examples is that consensus
true consensus consensus that does
appear to reflect underlying reality
about what is going on in the universe
takes time it never happens overnight
you don't
a pattern does not come to exist in the
world and immediately we know and
everyone agrees
and to consider any other possibility is
to
is to be a conspiracy theorist or
unscientific no quite the opposite
well all right in general that's going
to be true and i bet that's
always true in in our quadrant with uh
you know in in uh complexity space yep
this is probably uh
a given i'm thinking in particular of
um gravitational lensing
and einstein's insight that given
relativity that a massive object like
the sun
would appreciably bend starlight such
that it would be
uh visible from earth so there's i don't
know enough about the history of what
people were thinking
though so in that case there there was
an
opportunity due to an astronomical event
that allowed
that idea to be falsified or not right
and so
there was a moment before and after
which you could say there it is
this prediction was uh was
risky and we saw it and there we have it
um but in advance of the observation
um i don't know i don't know what the
collection of scientists were thinking
this is
yeah yeah i'm not an expert on it either
but i would say uh
we know that there was at least
diversity of opinion
and that the idea of uh space-time where
gravity is actually a warping of space
was certainly not thoroughly accepted
but my point
is that you get effect in in physics
you can get turning on a dime and so
what happened for those of you who don't
know the story is that there was a
total eclipse of the sun you can't
observe gravitational you need an object
really
because gravity is so weak you need an
object that's really large to bend light
enough that it can be easily detected
and the sun qualifies
the sun is big enough but the problem is
the sun puts out a lot of light of its
own
so it creates the impossibility of
seeing the stars behind it
right so what you need is an eclipse
that hides the sun's direct light and
allows you to see where the stars are
and the stars
move based on the gravity uh or
basically the space bends or the gravity
bends the
the light so but the point is there was
a famous excursion
to go view the total eclipse and the
point is the result of that
was uh resulted in i believe a very
rapid transition in people's acceptance
of this idea
well and so you know you said in
complexity space
what i had said about consensus takes
time is going to be true
and you know physics is fundamental
space rather than
emergent or complexity space generally
i wonder if another the analogy that
could lay directly on top of that almost
like an imperfect venn diagram
overlapping would be
um sort of population level thinking
that you know work that requires
population level thinking which is to
say
a recognition of a variance within a
population and you can
you know your immediate your your little
clues to figure out if the kind of work
you're doing or interested in thinking
about requires that is
are you going to need statistics in
order to figure out whether or not
you've got a pattern that is real as
opposed as opposed to
you've convinced yourself because your
biases are strong right and all of our
biases are strong that's you know that's
what science is for
so in order to reduce the uh power of
our biases and allow us to see reality
so you know population level work work
that requires statistics in order to
determine whether or not the pattern you
think you see is actually a pattern
that is different from what you would
expect by chance is very different from
einstein saying if this is true
then i am right and he and and his
and his logic was perfect his scientific
logic was perfect and all it took was
one event
because gravity isn't variant
in the way that the behavior of
mongooses is right
right okay or the behavior or or the
evolution of viruses
highly variant right we're going to have
variable outcomes
right okay so you've got examples
of what i would call natural consensus
where
the consensus arises out of the fact
that the evidence is
overwhelming and it eventually persuades
everybody
um who is paying attention to the
evidence and knows how hypothetical
deductive work
is done and then you have this other
phenomenon
which is the rush to consensus
for some reason and it's not going to be
obvious to people on the outside but in
effect
the idea that our most powerful notions
are the result of demonstrations that
produce a consensus
means that it is a tantalizing goal to
be able to claim that that is what has
happened in this case this case is
important to me
and it also has a consensus and so what
we see
in the case of for example the uh the
question
of the origin of sars v2
is a rush to claim that there is a
scientific consensus that this could not
possibly
have come from a lab and it must have
come from nature
and that consensus which was
widespread in certain circles was
completely unnatural and it was not
based on the evidence being compelling
and as a matter of fact
most of the elements of the hypothesis
that was put in front of us as to how
this
emerged from nature most of those
elements have since been falsified and
nobody believes them anymore the wet
market was not part of it pangolins were
not part of it
and so the um the consensus was about
something else
and i want to try another
just simplifying it's not really a
thought experiment but i want to just
try to
lay out where i think we find ourselves
with respect to
what it is that the people best
positioned the virologists
and epidemiologists how it is that we
might have arrived at consensus here
and i just want to draw this picture
one of two things must have happened
either the people who warned us
that there were diseases in nature just
waiting to find their way into humans
and one could cause a
terrible pandemic that would grind the
world
to a halt either those people were
right and their plea
to engage in a rapid program of studying
really dangerous viruses by enhancing
their
pathogenicity was
not early enough but it was the right
idea in which case
we should presumably be greatly
increasing the amount of research
resources we throw at gain of function
research or
these people caused a research program
that enhanced a virus
that then escaped and we are now
suffering the terrible consequences of
the research itself in which case the
belief system
of the same group of people has caused
all of this harm
and so i i just want to say
when we say well there's a consensus
among the people who are best positioned
to know where this virus might have come
from
we are talking about people who are
hovering
between two interpretations of what has
happened
if this is a natural virus then they
were prophetic
and they are the best hope for
preventing this from happening again
if this is laboratory in origin they are
responsible now i want to be i'm
not arguing for moral responsibility
here in the sense of
if this is a lab leak it's a massive
error in judgment
it is an international error but i do
not believe it is the result of bad
people i
believe it is the result of bad judgment
and we must learn the lessons
right and just asterisk there if it's a
lab leak
the evidence suggests that it is a lab
leak that is due to a collaboration
explicitly between
a lot of scientists at least in the
united states
and china and um presumably other places
as well
but specifically the u.s and china
there's no this isn't the china virus
this isn't
right none of that right it's the us and
china
and a community of scientists who were
very good at what they did
um and our government funding structures
all of these things are involved
now the i will say more i do want to
push back on your binary though i don't
think that's the i don't think that's
a fair characterization of you know what
you said was either or
either zoonotic diseases are a rising
threat
um zoonotic diseases being those that um
have been
endemic in some species and they jump to
a new species and generally
it's only when it jumps to a human
species that we tend to think of them
and call them zoonotic but you know any
any cross species transfer could be a
zoonotic disease i think
um that may be a semantic thing um you
know either that's true
or gain of function research and serial
passaging research
um have been have become
dominant in the sort of public health
vaccine development research game on
viruses and sonic diseases um
despite the fact that there is a
little chance of zoonotic diseases
emerging in this way which is as you
said on mar
it's unusual for for a virus to jump
and immediately be able to be both um
highly infectious of an individual into
which it jumps
and be able to move quickly between
hosts of its new species
it usually takes some time to adapt
and the serial passaging research that
is
we know is being done in various labs in
the u.s in china elsewhere
exactly would facilitate the virus to
viruses to be able to do such things but
i don't think it's in either or
right so um and actually i'll let you
get back to where you're going in just a
minute um zach if you would just show my
screen again i'll put a link up to this
uh for people who are interested in
pursuing it very interesting i find
article from oh i've forgotten when um
2010 sometime 2012 called
ecology of zoonoses natural and
unnatural histories
and it goes through exactly uh you know
it's it's not
it's it's not about lab leak this is
2012 right um but it it goes through how
changing you know human use of habitats
how changing population densities how
changing diet
how how all sorts of things that we are
doing in the world can change
the chances that a new zoonotic disease
will arise
and you know this is the kind of
analysis this work right here
by uh koresh and andy dobson and and
many many more
is the kind of theoretical work the you
know the review
of what is known and what the kinds of
parameters might be that we should be
considering
as we think about whether or not you
know our
so not a disease is just on the rise and
there's nothing we can do about it
well if they really are just on the rise
what is different from now than when
they weren't on the rise
right so you know i just i just wanted
to caution there
as an either or i think both can be true
both could be true
it could be that this is a lab leak and
it is also true that there are viruses
hovering out there ready to turn into a
pandemic that that is true and i
i thought about how to do this uh to
include that and it's it's too
complexifying because even if this is
the case
right if it is a lab leak then the fact
is
what we have done is increase the
chances of facing
a pandemic by solving a problem that
most viruses cannot solve
right how to get into a new species and
spread within it is a difficult puzzle
not impossible but difficult and so
still from the point of view i mean
remember my point here is really about
human beings
and how they are likely to decide what
has happened
based on either being the villains in a
story or the heroes of the story
and uh again i do want to say also
i think that this is you know as i said
on mar last night and as i will
go into later here probably i'll talk a
little bit about the
probabilities but uh i think this is
highly probable that this came from a
laboratory it was the result of gain of
function research
the instinct to do that research i
believe to have been
a massive error the culpability
goes to the collective that decided to
allow this
if this is what has happened this
changes
though at the point that the obviously
viable hypothesis that this disease has
emerged
from a laboratory is shut down
with false consensus right that we
actually have a
right to know and even if that right to
know
involves a completely open investigation
of the lab leak hypothesis that proves
it didn't happen
right we have a right to go that route
rather than have this
shut down so that we know how to protect
ourselves going forward and at the point
that you block that conversation and you
demonize people
who would start it now you do have
culpability and the fact that life and
limb
is riding on this means that
those who are blocking the conversation
to the extent that they are aware that
this is actually much more plausible
than they are letting on
they are taking responsibility for the
deaths that happen that could have been
prevented if we had simply been allowed
to investigate this question
absolutely i 100 agree uh before
you talk a little bit about where you
arrive at
your estimates of probabilities which
you were also doing
on you know we we started this uh this
live stream back in late march
when um very recently at that point the
who and the surgeon general were
advising everyone not to wear masks and
we had been wearing masks in public
before anyone else was and feeling kind
of awkward about it but it
obviously if it's a respiratory disease
that's what you should do to stop the
spread i was the bandit of our local
hardware you
were the bandit of the location after
everybody started wearing masks people
would comment when i came back and you
were the guy who came in here wearing
your bandanna
back when nobody else was excellent um
so let me just um
in service of there are some voices
in the in the scientific establishment
who have been saying this
it is what we are not hearing for the
most part is these voices in the media
so zach i just want to show a couple of
um
papers from my screen again here we have
a nature paper
from 2015 engineered bat virus stirs
debate over risky research
lab made coronavirus related to sars can
infect human cells
that was in 2015 okay and then just two
for now there's there are a lot of these
here we have proceedings of the national
academy of sciences
um in 2020 this is november of 2020
just you know two months ago opinion to
stop the next pandemic we need to
unravel the origins of covet 19.
here we have finally and increasingly
scientists in the establishment with you
know with
faculty and research positions saying
actually
no this consensus was arrived at far too
fast without sufficient data and not
only
is that unscientific it's dangerous
yes and we should also point i i we will
never probably know but we
are have arrived at the place where we
can now begin to have this conversation
in public
without the stigmas that come back
having a devastating effect we have
arrived there in large measure because
of the
so-called drastic group who organized on
twitter some of these people
are known some of them are anonymous but
this is a group of very dedicated
scientists
who have uh doggedly chased down all of
these leads and
unearthed important pieces of
information that we now have at our
disposal
and so anyway there's a lot more to be
said about the drastic group
and uh how they accomplished what they
did but um
for the moment let's just say we owe
them a huge debt of gratitude
and uh i hope that the full impact
of their hard work is is ultimately
understood in this story
very good all right so uh whatever you
want i'll talk about diet but i think
you have some other things you want to
do first
yeah all right so um looks like you've
been colonized though yes i have been uh
colonized by this uh this fine felid
um zach do you want to put up the
diagram i sent you
so i just wanted to show um so uh my
statement last night that in june it
turns out to have been may but i said on
mar that i thought as far back as
june i had rated the chances
of a gain of function lab leak as
90 and this is something you would have
shared on whatever episode that was yeah
i did
putting this out i absolutely put it up
so this is my flowchart it was my
attempt to
label all the major possibilities um
for how kobe 19 pandemic
could have begun including things like
uh the
wuhan uh wet market which is on there
so these these are your estimates these
are my estimates you know you
you give us no receipts here yeah well i
mean you know any one of these things
could be uh but let's just pick you know
one or two and not let me out you know
how do you you know how do you arrive at
uh i don't even know which which one
would you like me to which one would you
like to explain how you arrive let's
talk about the one on the far
right over there since bill mentioned it
last night intentional release
uh yeah the intentional release of the
virus i have it at
uh less than one percent of probability
for those of
for those of you who are listening
rather than watching um
this is again a uh
a flow chart that brett made where you
start at a wild coronavirus and you end
up at the cove at 19 pandemic and he has
various probabilities your estimates in
between that include
bat to human v intermediate such as a
pangolin
um then through human or wuhan seafood
market or directly
something that happened in the in the
labs
based on pure research or bioweapon
research
or um you know or you know was a lab
leak versus intentional release so those
are
it's i'm not going to be able to
describe the visual right for those who
are just listening but i attempted to
put
a pathway up here that covers all of the
plausible
explanations there's not really crazy
stuff the virus didn't come from space
we don't have to worry
about that so those things aren't on
here but every plausible thing is
embedded at least on one of these paths
and so the reason that uh intentional
release
is down below one percent but it's on
here
is that um it's very hard to distinguish
uh a gain of function
virus a virus that has been enhanced
through gain of function research for
weapons purposes from one that was done
for biomedical purposes and in fact
the research is arguably dual purpose
right so we don't know who funds it why
what's
going on we don't know what we don't
know and
um so let me just say i have seen
zero evidence that there is a bias dual
purpose
meaning defensive against a presumably
naturally emerging zoonotic disease
and potentially then also useful as an
offensive
weapon right now we've set up up front
when this is a
a much newer pandemic that um this
didn't
this virus did not appear to behave in a
way that it would be a highly effective
weapon
obviously it has created a huge amount
of economic chaos so who knows what who
might be thinking
but anyway the intentional release
if it happened if somebody had enhanced
the virus somewhere they might have
released it in wuhan
so that the wuhan institute of virology
would take the blame they might
effectively have framed the wuhan
institute it's very hard to falsify that
notion that would explain
the wuhan institute's reaction which is
uh
we were shocked and worried when we saw
this virus showed up but now we know it
had nothing to do with us
on the other hand they haven't behaved
in a way
that a lab that had nothing to hide
would tend to behave a lab that had
nothing to hide would tend to say hey
take a look at our books take a look at
our freezers
right this wasn't us uh we know how it
looks but you know you're welcome to
check our notebooks and that is the
opposite of what has happened so
in any case i would say there is one
weird fact that showed up very recently
just one
well there are many weird facts and
there are many percentages here on this
chart that
i would change now but um the
uh who commission looking into
laboratory origins a commission
which clearly has conflicts of interest
based on
peter dashick being on this
this panel has said something to the
effect of it's too early to even say
that the virus started
in china now i don't know what the hell
they're talking about
but if they have something of that
nature
um you know and i i don't i don't know
what to make of it
i must say i'm everything i hear from uh
this panel is going to be taken with a
grain of salt until they establish they
can do the work honestly
like so many of these statements you
know that that could be
exactly the kind of due diligence that
you want from a team of international
researchers who are trying to figure out
this thing
that has you know decimated life's lives
and economies right
right um you know or it could be a faint
and sort of you know this is this is a
potemkin panel that does
isn't actually interested in figuring
out what uh where
where this thing started for why we may
never know
right they they could be trying to get
ahead of the story they've clearly
lost the ability to shut down the
discussion about lab leak you know they
only got away for so long with accusing
us of being conspiracy theorists and now
that's that
that uh accusation has just lost its
sting
um so who knows
of course well of course but the point
is people are listening less and less
because there are
enough credible voices saying actually
you know there are four different kinds
of evidence that are pointing in this
direction
i do wonder actually i mean i do wonder
those who have been
you know shouting loudest about those of
us who've been talking loudly
about being conspiracy theorists are
they
if if if lab leak turns out to be
something that
is um discovered to be true and
you know whether or not that therefore
is you know something
of a cover-up on the order of like
chernobyl right um
if if lab leak turns out to be true
how many of the people who have been
saying
not only is lab leak not true you are
irresponsible to talk about it
how many of them are actually going to
own up
to the anti-scientific rhetoric that
they engaged in
oh i don't expect that at all and
frankly the typical thing
would be even people who saw the story
for what it was and who were falsely
demonized will not have their
reputations resurrected
um so there's some you know obviously
something eric has talked about
extensively but the uh
the distributed uh idea suppression
complex what he calls the
disc is a very effective mechanism
for deciding who gets to speak on issues
and the who gets to speak isn't really
about who turned out to be right in the
end
right it's a lot about power so
anyway um i would say
you know this chart was obviously done
back in may
the uh idea that the wet market was
involved was still a live idea that
idea has now been falsified by the
chinese
many of the initial cases who had no
connection to the
wuhan seafood market so interesting that
you had that
five times higher than the idea of an
intentional release well the thing is an
intentional release an intentional
release would have to be one of two
things
i think or some version of it either
would have to be
the wuhan institute in which case they
wouldn't release it
in wuhan that would be insane
right or it would have to be somebody
framing the wuhan institute
in which case i would want to see some
kind of evidence of that before
you know worrying about it so anyway uh
less than one percent is meant to
indicate
it's very hard to falsify this idea but
there's no positive evidence for it and
until there's some positive evidence
it's just not you know it's on the chart
you just have to leave it up there as a
possibility
yeah yeah um
so all right so anyway um i would
actually say the chances of a lab leak
has gone down
very slightly even though the evidence
for lab leak has gotten
better and better and better over time
what's what's that about
well it's about the possibility that
there's another route that would have
done the same thing
so like i said there are multiple kinds
of evidence
pointing in the direction of a lab leak
some of them having to do with
you know circumstantial evidence of the
way the lab behaved the deletion
of databases the bizarre
relabeling of sample 4991 as ratg13
there's all sorts of stuff that makes
the lab
look suspicious there's phylogenetic
evidence
there's molecular evidence there's
epidemiological evidence that point in
this direction
point of order though i do i don't know
where you're going in terms of um
why you think even though the evidence
is growing the chances that it's a lab
leak have actually gone down slightly
that's a
that's an amazing sentence um
the phylogenetic evidence to which you
just alluded
uh is if if memory serves that there was
this
virus that infected six minors in
a province almost a thousand miles away
in 2013
yunnan right and um that it is
something over 90 somewhere like 96
similar or something i don't have the
numbers in front of me
uh two stars cove two and the fact that
it is um so
to to us and to many people who are
thinking about this carefully and have
an evolutionary framework
um that seems like
that that that provides some evidence
that this that is that was the sort of
the backbone virus
on which some serial passage research
from gain of function research was
done and you would expect the resultant
virus
to be you know very similar and then
quite
different at a few notable spots right
and
um i have heard mainstream virologists
and epidemiologists
claiming that the fact that it is not
identical
to sars cove ii is in fact the
phylogenetic evidence against
a lab leak so i just like so so this
point i think is
is fascinating because exactly the same
data
are are being interpreted by us and
others as
that is that makes it at least possible
and perhaps probable
that that was the backbone on which gain
of function research was done
hence the differences and is interpreted
by
others as see there is no possibility
that this escaped from a lab because
it's not identical to
the virus um that was discovered in
2013.
right so it's just like this is
sometimes how science looks and that i'm
not saying that everyone involved here
is acting in good faith and with
complete honor
i hope that they are i don't know that
but sometimes you have exactly the same
data
and wildly opposite interpretations yeah
that was not really
uh the phylogenetic evidence i was i was
pointing to i would say you know the
failure of the overall
sars kobe 2 virus to settle at one
position in the phylogeny that it has
you know overwhelming similarity in one
way
uh to other beta coronaviruses and then
it has
weird spike protein stuff from somewhere
else don't belong in beta coronaviruses
at all well there's the fern site which
doesn't belong
in beta coronaviruses where it's
literally never been seen in nature and
yet here it is
and so yeah it's been found it develops
in serial passage research on in things
like
mink right probably ferret although
ferret and ferret or mink yeah
fahrenheit very very very close related
and then it also uh the fern cleavage
sites have developed in poultry farms
so in um in basically domesticated you
know agricultural
situations and in research labs but
never in the wild
right so anyway it's a phylogenetic
anomaly is it impossible to explain it
um through some natural pathway not
impossible but it's uh it's
going to be difficult and what we would
need to see is some evidence
that actually there was something
capable of doing the heavy lifting
right because we cannot just you know uh
phony up a pangolin and you know imagine
that that explains anything because it
turns out it doesn't yeah they get saucy
when you do that too
so the the one the reason that i think
um there's a slight decrease in the
chances of gain of function
research at the wuhan institute being
responsible is that the
chances that so back in may
we didn't know anything about outbreaks
in mix
okay we've now seen that minks get and
transmit the disease so there have been
these
little mini epidemics inside these mink
farms lots of minks have been destroyed
okay that is in and of itself very
interesting
right there's a perfectly natural way
that could arise
out of gain of function research in
which ferrets or minx had been used for
serial passaging which is that the virus
is not new
to this clade so yeah for those of you
who
aren't mustelid experts i realize most
of you are you'll just have to you know
maybe take a pee break or something but
um for the people who aren't still at
experts experts a mustelid
being that clade of organisms that
includes
minks and ferrets yeah it's the weasel
clade um
so that clade and minks and ferrets are
i believe
sister they are very close each other's
closest extent relatives
i think i'm not i'm not sure i believe
that's right i believe that there's
also the possibility of interbreeding
which would again say very close but
nonetheless um the idea is if a virus
can get into a creature that it's not
been in but very typically when it gets
in it has very low capacity of any
capacity at all to get between
individuals right so you can get sick
from a wild animal but it's not the same
thing as saying you're going to get sick
and everybody you know is going to get
it too because the chances are the virus
won't know how to get out of you
and into them but in the case of minx
wow right now we've seen others we've
seen other stuff like
um cats big and cats big and small
gorillas in zoos anyway yeah now
the cats as far as i know can't transmit
it they can get sick
but there's no evidence that they can
transmit it same goes i think there's
some cases of dogs um so it's the case
that you would expect which is the virus
is
infective it can leap but then it can't
uh it can't leap again yeah
uh okay so anyway spill over to use the
language
right now i'm a little bit concerned
saying this out loud but i think it's
better just to
say it out loud and let's have a
completely open discussion about it
the reason do you still want your screen
up as it's been oh you can put
a lot of
the reason for my slight adjustment to
the lab leak explanation is that the
possibility
exists for some story
to have had a bat infect minx in a mink
farm this would still be a
self-inflicted wound in the sense that
the way we farm minks would open the
possibility
of an accidental natural passage
experiment
in minks that were housed very densely
that could have explained the evolution
of certain characteristics that we now
see
very hard to distinguish between that
having happened on a mink farm versus
having happened in a laboratory
i wouldn't explain it all but um anyway
i think the past the fact that there are
mink farms apparently
uh in china and that there's some story
like that that could
happen yeah is worth uh entertaining as
possible that's interesting and i happen
i happen to have a paper relevant to
that queued up too that i
wasn't going to talk about but you can
just show it briefly this is another
2012 paper from pinas from the
proceedings
national academy um called zoonosis
emergence linked to agricultural
intensification and environmental change
so this what you just suggested
is basically adding the caveat and thus
adjusting your probabilities
based on the new evidence that you
didn't have in may um that you that
there are outbreaks and mink farms
yeah okay so not expecting so anyway
most of the
most of the probability that i would put
on something like that is borrowed from
the collapse of uh of the
wet market explanation pangolins etc
but nonetheless so we're still at a very
high percentage
and you know look that high percentage
is not a
scientific conclusion in the sense of it
is not the result of the scientific
method it's the result of something like
a bayesian analysis
of the various probabilities and you
know
the way the scientific method works we
put the hypotheses on the table
and we attempt to falsify them and at
the point
all have fallen but one that one becomes
a theory
so this is the reason we are sticklers
around here to say that the lab leak
hypothesis is a hypothesis and not a
theory i should say
bill maher and his people who have a
a wonderful well-oiled machine of a
an organization they put up a clip of us
and they had labeled it unfortunately
something like lab leak theory and i
asked them if they could change it to
hypothesis
and they were right on it so i think the
youtube clip has been changed and the
others it's going to have to wait until
monday but anyway
thank you very much for for adjusting
that it really
helps us keep the discussion careful to
be
vigilant about the distinction between
theory and hypothesis
yeah all right should we talk about um
diet a little bit
let's do it let's do that um what are we
at we're at
uh oh closing in an hour at this point
okay so
um there are four papers or so there are
more than that but um
you know it's early yet and there are
four papers
that went looking at whether or not you
might explain something about
um about the copen19 pandemic in terms
of both
likelihood of people getting infected
and people do get infected
whether or not you know how how sick
they get
if diet has any effect on those things
so diet could
mitigate the severity of your symptoms
and might actually change whether or not
you get it at all and of course at this
point
um you know a even if we had the
resources
this is not the sort of thing you're
going to be doing experimental work on
probably so it's purely correlational
and it's basically looking at you know
widespread like what kinds of diets
do people in you know different parts of
india eat
and in different parts of europe so the
two big studies that i've um that i
spent some time with again
big correlational so suggestive but not
um not decisive by any means
that we're largely looking at
differences in
in cobin 19 rates of
diagnosis and outcomes for those who got
sick
across europe and in india one of these
papers
is called
oh no it it dropped me out that's not
nice of it at all there it is
okay so one of these papers is from july
of last year
by um i'm probably going to mispronounce
their name busquet
busquet all published in allergy
i think unless i've got that wrong um
yeah allergy cabbage and fermented
vegetables from death rate heterogeneity
in countries to candidates for
mitigation strategies of severe covet
19.
interesting paper this one and i want to
just walk us through a little bit
of table 1 in here and then talk a bit
um
more broadly about some of the findings
from the other papers
so we have here this is you know again
this is
they've done a good job of not
pretending to quantify when they really
had no ability to
so this this kind of looks like you know
they have given
one to four pluses here to try to give
an estimate
but it's kind of like you know it's kind
of like what you did with your flow
chart like you know what
based on the available evidence this is
what i think is going on and so they've
said based on the available evidence
what do each of these risk factors
possible risk factors
how are they going to explain
geographical differences
in covert rates and outcomes at both the
individual level
and the country and region level and i'm
not going to spend any time really
talking about the distinction there um
but you know right and they
it's more or less organized excuse me
organized from you know most most
intensive effects
to least so contact with the sars kobe 2
infected individual
that is likely to do it right if
anything is that's going to do it
um intensity of social contacts
intensity of occupational contacts
and confinement um with with such people
all of these things are high and this is
no news to anyone watching this right
we moved down a little bit and though
and they've got diet
and food and long food chain supply and
traditional fermented food as the things
that they begin to talk about newly oh
but before we even get there vitamin d
so something you and i have been talking
about for a long time probably since
march on this
on this podcast is um
other viruses seem to do more poorly
in humans not all of them some other
viruses seem to do more poorly in humans
the course of the disease is lessened
the severity of the symptoms are lower
when those people are able to get out in
the sun
so um yes you can get vitamin d in a
pill form but for all of these things it
is
almost certain that if you get it in the
form that you know it comes to you in
the form of food or in the case of
vitamin d in the form of sunlight
uh it's probably going to be more
efficacious and so they they
revisit the vitamin d question um they
find
uh when they're just mapping diet onto
um
on to covet outcomes that um
low prevalence in asia and africa both
suggest a role for diet
and specifically they find in the next
line here with regard to food
uh that fermented food and this is this
shows up
twice here that fermented
food is uh for for a number of reasons
and again i think at this point we don't
really have time to get
into the into the diet science too much
um may well be protective
against i may be both getting an
extremity of disease ideology in copen
19.
so specifically they talk about both raw
cabbage interestingly
uh ferments like sauerkraut and kimchi
yogurt
and so within europe they found i think
it was like turkey
and balkans which have a lot of of
yogurt consumption and then a lot of
parts of germany
which have a lot of ferment consumption
having
lower rates than the areas around them
which also have different cuisines
and then and this was
this is one of these things that you and
i would refer to as obvious in
retrospect it had never occurred to me
before but as soon as i saw this
in in this paper i thought yeah that
that makes sense
long food chain supply um
seems to be a long supply chain for your
food
yeah and i i just read that off here and
i realized that's not actually that's
that's not organized the right way long
supply chain for your
food meaning uh that it took
more steps and probably came from
farther away
from where it was initially grown to get
to you
is is known from other research to be
associated with metabolic disorders okay
so that is fascinating and obvious
because you know what does a long
um uh how do i order it the right way
supply chain for food um tend to mean
it's about food being highly processed
having some of its parts taken out and
then maybe added back in
as if those nutrients were always there
so it's pieces parts it's productionist
and it ends up being shelf stable maybe
freezer stable
it is it is very much not um
often representative of what the
original food was
and what we will see um and you know
maybe this is actually the moment to
switch
so zach if i can have my screen back
from some of the other papers
is that specifically uh plant-based diet
high fiber diet high ferment diet
and um and one more thing that i'm not
going to mention yet while we're just
talking about all this
all seem to be correlated with
negatively correlated with obesity
with metabolic syndrome with long
supply chain for food and
with positively correlated with good
outcomes for covid
so you know if if you're looking for
sort of diet advice you know we we
know that obesity is one of the main
comorbidities for covet 19
and we don't get to talk about it
because we don't want to be fat shaming
which is
ridiculous pretending that something is
isn't good for you is not going to make
that thing go away we do not actually
live
in a socially constructed post-modernist
universe so
well what's more we're denying people a
honest-to-goodness proper incentive to
get uh
to get in charge of their weight
on the basis that yes okay obesity is
bad for you it's especially bad for you
in light of something like
covid and to not talk about the
protective
uh uh aspect of being at a reasonable
weight is you know you're hurting the
people that you're trying to protect by
not shaming them so
it just makes it makes no sense it makes
no sense and um
we have i don't remember which paper
it's in talks about the inflammatory
properties of things like
red meat you know we're not vegetarians
we eat red meat so
this is not about saying you need to
adopt this diet and you know we're
perfect here we eat vegetarians for
breakfast
i don't i don't eat breakfast
red meat gluten largely in wheat
and alcohol are all understood to be
inflammatory
and background inflammat inflammation
um seems to be contributing again to
things like metabolic syndrome
and weight gain and once you have weight
gain you have obesity so there's you
know there's at least
one through line one direct line to um
from some of these things to uh okay
maybe modifying your diet uh of you know
you've always wanted to and here you go
like
this may actually help you stay safer
in an era of you know who knows emerging
zoonotic diseases
or diseases created um you know for us
by people interested in
doing research um
regardless they're out there this one's
out there and there will probably be
more
and how is it that we should be trying
to keep ourselves safe
one more thing um
actually no two more two a couple more
things
here's a quote from uh
a different busque at all paper so same
lead author this one titled is diet
partly responsible for differences in
coven 19 death rates between within
countries
they say foods with potent antioxidant
or anti-ace activity
like uncooked or fermented cabbage are
largely consumed in low death rate
european countries
korea and taiwan and might be considered
in the low prevalence of deaths
again correlational there's no ability
to establish a causal relationship here
um and then just to go back to the
supply chain issue
quote the increasing availability of
foods from big retail is a revolutionary
event that has impacted
crops favoring those that have the best
ratio of effectiveness over cost of
production
and health at a population size level in
particular such a change in food
availability has altered elementary
habits
promoting sugar enriched vitamin d
populated foods and has become one of
the causes of the obesity epidemic
especially among adolescents
these foods come from centralized farms
and selected areas of the world that are
distributed around the planet
elongating the supply chain of food the
impact of long supply chain of food on
health is measurable by an increase in
metabolic syndrome
and insulin resistance so the one more
thing
that we haven't mentioned yet that these
papers suggest
might might be implicated as a useful
dietary tool to avoid
or mitigate the impacts of covid is
intermittent fasting
interestingly so a different paper
reishidol diet gut microbiota and cova
19
says intermittent fasting which includes
alternate day fasting or time restricted
feeding
has been reported to favorably influence
the gut microbiota by increasing the
abundance of beneficial acromensia
mucinophilia and bacteroides fragilis in
fact various animal trials and some
human intervention studies have clearly
demonstrated health benefits associated
with iaf in people with underlying
diabetes
obesity and cardiovascular ailments
and these authors of memory serves
specifically find
pockets demographic pockets of people
who were effectively forced into
intermittent fasting because they didn't
have enough food
due to the epidemic due to the pandemic
who had better outcomes when they did
end up
getting the disease so again
correlational we can't know for sure
but um super interesting and suggestive
and for those who
have never heard of intermittent fasting
before you know it can be anything from
you eat only for eight hours a day and
not at all from for 16
to you don't eat anything for two days a
week you know lots of different
options all right well that is
uh quite consistent with what what we've
been seeing
so the the upshot is diet especially
short
supply chain fermented foods go outside
get your vitamin d
make vitamin d while the sun shines as
they never say that's right
um they don't say it and what that also
means is if you're outside and you're
not around anyone else
get the sun on your face you don't need
to be wearing a mask if you're outside
not around anyone else
and um it's it's been shocking to us
from the beginning
that outside areas were shut down and
it's one thing if you really can't
control
the density and people are crowded
really close to one another but
so far so far even these new variants
don't seem to be spreading outside
okay all right well it seems to me that
we've arrived at
you promised sea stars dude i did yeah
we've arrived seasonally
that's what i was of course i wasn't
gonna leave the podcast without
covering this okay but um no the segway
to sea stars though
is through a different marine uh marine
element we're gonna go tuna first
okay could we go tuna first yep okay so
um
this is the wapo article washington post
um
subways tuna is not tuna but a mixture
of various concoctions
a lawsuit alleges so um
really that's that's we just need the
headline uh that's that's kind of all
you need you know it's just just been
taken to court we don't know for sure
although some independent analysis found
um that the tuna in the tuna is not
tuna why should we care what what
like oh we should care yes we should
care i think we should but why should we
care so
most people i think will have this
reaction of like that's not okay
but why like why actually should we care
well a
you you have a right to know and you
know as i've discovered
as someone who has apparently a severe
wheat allergy it is hard enough even if
people
attempt to report what's in
food to avoid this thing that does
substantial harm to some of us
because of you know small bits of
contamination
but if people are actually distorting
what it is that you're eating then your
ability to detect what hurts you
and your ability to police your own diet
just drops to to zero and i remember i
mean
my guess is this is going to be a whole
suite of stories ultimately
if this turns out to be true and the
tuna really isn't tuna
it reminds me of the story where
supermarket honey
turned out most of it to be unrelated to
honey it was some sugar concoction
and the way this was detected was that
it is impossible
to produce honey without getting pollen
in it and so by buying supermarket
honey and testing for pollen and
discovering that a large fraction of it
had no pollen whatsoever in it
was discovered that it was synthetic so
anyway it's another incidentally it's
another risk
of a longer supply chain for your food
that if you if you don't have a close
relation you know
having a close relationship to the
people who are producing your food or
producing your food yourself
um precludes some of these eventualities
absolutely
and you know so this is again a place
where the precautionary principle
is everything you know it seems like
well i source my food
you know at the supermarket rather than
the farmer it's only a couple miles away
right
it seems similar but the fact is it's
all the difference in the world because
all of the things that
a what in order to get you an apple from
across the country yeah right the apple
has to be
a different apple effectively yes um and
so you know the food has been selected
for
this at the expense of that trade-offs
are ubiquitous and so in order to get it
you know you end up with a tommy atkins
mango exactly where i was gonna go like
our experience having spent a lot of
time in the tropics doing research
is um like i i never understood why
people liked bananas
until we started doing research in the
tropics and i had
you know what i think of is real bananas
and of course they're still not because
you know if you've ever noticed that
bananas don't have seeds
so you know the modern banana is a human
concoction
but the bananas that are growing um down
in
at least in the neotropics the little
tiny bananas are so much more flavorful
as are the mangoes that you get straight
off a tree
in you know in in the neotropical
champagne mangoes and all and if you
know if the only mango you've ever had
is a tommy adkins mango which was
specifically selected to
endure transport the thing is god-awful
right it's not a good mango and um the
it doesn't you are you are going to
anger the tommy atkins mango enthusiasts
oh they can go straight to hell because
no there are no tommy atkins mango
enthusiasts you don't grow tommy atkins
no i i don't i don't think that's true
because i think there are plenty of
people
who have been introduced to mangoes in
american supermarkets
and have never had what we
think of as and i'm comfortable calling
a real mango and so you know you get if
you i mean i love mangoes but you really
love mangoes yes i do
and i feel like if you would only if you
had never traveled if you had never done
research all the places you've done
research that we've done research
um you might well taste of kamiakin's
mango just you know in the in that
season
when yes it's been bred for transport
but it's actually available
and think yeah i really like this fruit
well all right i want to take my go
straight to healthy because i thought
you were gonna say the people who grow
tommy atkins mangoes were the people
uh that i was gonna anger and you know
they can go to hell but
um but people who like them if you
haven't had the chance to have another
then
i would just advise you can now get good
champagne
mangoes and i'm blanking on the name of
the other one
it'll come to me but anyway there are
good the mangoes that have no red on
them
that you know they look more boring
they're smaller but
really good flavor have those and have
them ripe and it's a whole different
ball game from that time yeah
interesting
and i mean part of excuse me part of
we're far afield from tuna here but part
of the issue
also with uh long supply chains for your
food
and buying everything under wrap and
pre-processed
in the supermarket is that you lose a
sense of the seasonality of food and of
life and of everything that's going on
outside your climate-controlled
home and if you start if
if you start to realize that actually um
peppers are a summer fruit as are stone
fruits
and yes you can probably get stone fruit
in january if you're having them shipped
from chile or i don't even know where
you know south africa may be
somewhere in the southern hemisphere
where the seasons are opposite
you you can get them they're never going
to be as good
your supply chain for your food just got
way long
and it's actually in my experience
super pleasurable to have as some part
of your sort of
weekly and seasonal rhythm going ah it's
soon going to be
citrus season it's soon going to be
strawberry season
spinach whatever right and um
and you know having that to look forward
to and then you know eating
eating the food at its peak when it is
locally most delicious and obviously
this doesn't work as well for everyone
depending on where they're living
but also means that what you what you
get when you go for those
for those three four five depending on
the year
weeks that the pacific northwest has the
june bearing strawberries and they are
the best food in the universe we're here
in portland oregon
and those strawberries are out of this
world
and the strawberries and not very
durable so we can't
they you know they don't get shipped
elsewhere because they don't survive
right and the strawberries that you get
from the same farms growing strawberries
right next to those
berries in august using the same
techniques
same soil same terroir just don't
compare because an ever-bearing plant
has been selected for something else and
it can't maximize
both ever-bearing and flavor at the same
time and this is you know this this is
this is the evolutionary lens right like
trade-offs and everything all right
so we want to pair these two things
though there's something to be said for
eating stuff at its peak
right that's locally available and
there's something to be said for eating
the stuff that humans have cleverly
figured out how to preserve
right so yeah this is the ferment stuff
yes so the fact is we have all of these
things that we modern people think of
as um you know aesthetic in nature i
think i could go for a pickle
right but the pickle is a mechanism for
taking
a uh a non-durable
bit of plant and preserving it so that
you can eat it when you're going to need
it rather than when it's
you know ripe on on the vine and you
know
we could say the same thing about you
know
cheese and uh you know sauerkraut and
kimchi as you mentioned before
all of these things were developed as a
way of stabilizing
these uh fresh foods by spoiling them in
a way that is particularly
um healthy and the fact is they have
extra benefits as you
point to in that paper about uh
kombucha belongs on the list too oh sure
sure does so anyway
interestingly though you know the other
thing that belongs on the list of
amazing techniques for preserving food
and thus being able to eat your calories
after the food would have spoiled
is beer which is liquid bread and you
know we know that gluten is you know
even if you're you know even if you're
like
a lot of us who don't seem to have a
particular gluten sensitivity unlike you
gluten is inflammatory yeah um and it
doesn't seem to
you know just be the glyphosate for
instance right um but
but beer but is full of nutrition full
of calories because it's it's drinking
your bread
yeah just to be clear i don't think the
glyphosate is the thing that we
react to i think it causes something
that then makes a sensitive to wheat so
it is
clear from my own experience that i have
a reaction to organic wheat it doesn't
help me at all that it's organic and
therefore presumably free of any
glyphosate whatsoever i am now sensitive
to molecules in wheat however that
happened
yeah but all right
it seems to me that we still maybe i
missed it in there somewhere
but i know that we were gonna talk about
sea stars
were we i think we were okay all right
why don't you start since you know what
the topic is no it's real it's really
just
a a tiny little thing um and you know
maybe later we should revisit behavior
in sea stars and and
other things and we've actually been
when we've been doing other research
we've been
able to see some pretty amazing amalgams
of sea stars in places but
um no i was going back through and doing
some of the um just deep history fact
checking for the chapter of our book a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century
um that goes back through the entire
history of life on earth
it's just one chapter that is like that
and um
and sea stars which are echinoderms are
the closest relatives of grenades
vertebrates basically
and one of the distinguishing features
of vertebrates is that we have bilateral
symmetry right we have you know there's
a there's an axis of symmetry and
you can roughly we're not exactly
symmetrical but you know along that
that that sagittal axis uh
no that's a no it's not that's not
satchel axis
yeah i think it is yeah poi sure
sagittal crest i mean he's right on that
axis
you know i used to teach comparative
anatomy and know this stuff really
really well it's been a few years at
this point
along that side access you could
basically fold us in half and get mirror
images right and this is true for
um for all the vertebrates so um
i was thinking and i really should have
known better but i was thinking ah
bilateral symmetry
evolved at the level of vertebrates
because look at our closest relatives
the sea stars they clearly have radial
symmetry right
you have a point um out from which you
have
a radiation and the symmetry is in that
in in sort of those directions as
opposed to along an axis
but no there is of course the much
bigger and older group the bilateria
uh where bilateral symmetry originated
and the sea stars
have reversed they've given it up
and they haven't given it up entirely
because their larvae
are still bilaterally symmetrical so sea
star larvae still have a left and a
right
and then as adults they just say screw
this
i'm done i'm going radial symmetry and
just
you know developmental biology is still
in some ways in its infancy
some of some of the really important
early stuff happened 100 years ago but
um there's still so much that we don't
know and even even things around axis
formation is
um super hard for us to us to grok
um but for me you know in no way being a
developmental biologist
the idea of a larval form going from
bilaterally symmetrical to radially
symmetrical
is you know almost enough for me to have
a religious revelation
it's kind of amazing it's pretty it's
pretty interesting so
all right so evolutionarily bilateral
about bilateral symmetry has been lost
it has evolved
away in this highly successful
group of creatures yeah that's um
fascinating and
unexpected um at least to me i would say
the lesson
uh for our viewers is uh bilateral
symmetry
use it or lose it right yes oh
definitely want to remain
bilaterally symmetrical at least in you
know the long haul then
i would say uh you know do stuff that
uses that and that'll uh
potentially preserve it it's like
lamarckian bilateral symmetry
i'm struggling to find a lesson that
will be relevant to our to our audience
that may not have been
uh such a good one but on the fly i feel
like it was i'm not sure this is a
usable piece of information it's just
fascinating
if you're the kind of person who's
fascinated by these things can we agree
that it won't hurt
to use it use your bilateral symmetry
take a run it's not going to be bad for
them they'll get out in the sun they'll
make some vitamin d
so use it or lose it better safe than
sorry
yep yeah makes sense yep and if you find
yourself doing cartwheels you might be
tending
over towards radial symmetry boy that's
a point
yep that's why i never took up
cartwheeling is that why it's one of the
reasons i also never managed to complete
a full cartwheel
i didn't want to be mistaken for a
rotifer maybe i didn't want to hurt
myself
i would love to be able to do a
cartwheel it looks like a tremendous
amount of fun
but it there's i'm courageous about
certain things yes you are that's not
one of them
okay um well
uh did we want to show uh the so we've
got a thumb
we've started to do thumbnails now of
photos that we've taken the previous
week as opposed to
shots of us and and whatever cat has
wandered by um
so this is a this is a picture i took um
in a storefront in the pearl district of
portland
uh earlier this week and it struck me
it's obviously appealing a little bit
um as appropriate given the context of
our conversation around consensus
science
that many people now are saying trust
the science
follow the science uh and you know
because science
and we are here to say in part
um absolutely try to engage
in scientific thinking and scientific
problem solving
as much as you can in the world
and guess what trusting authorities is
actually
antithetical to that process
yeah um i was thinking about this a bit
on the plane and i should say this was
our first uh
plane flight in some time and yeah
almost almost a full year you had flown
down once before in like june to do
to do joe rogan yeah but before covid
you and i were
we had gotten very good at getting on
planes getting places you know
we knew how to pack and all that stuff
and all i can say basically forgotten if
you are if you are like
us and you know you had that dialed in
and you haven't been doing it for the
last year
your next trip you may want to budget a
little
extra time just so you don't forget
anything i think one or two
extra days would be sufficient to make
sure you don't forget anything but the
number of mistakes we made in traveling
was spectacular but all right back to
you i'm glad we had each other
yes no like something terrible might
have happened if i literally walked off
the plane without my bag
never done that before yeah just walked
off totally unlike you yeah
um okay so in any case i was thinking on
the plane about
trust the science and there's something
about it it's like um what do the data
say
data is king data driven science where
these things
sound so right but then it turns out
that they are actually
battle cries of a faction that's
actually undoing something important
and you're interested in rapid consensus
right yeah trust the science
sounds so right but the problem is the
right it's like the last day in mega the
the entrust
the science is the place where the uh
the ill deeds are done and the point is
if you said
trust science i'd be on board because
what that means is
the method if you've come to a bad
conclusion the
cure for bad science is more in better
science trust science
yeah i do trust science it doesn't mean
i inherently trust scientists i would
like scientists to be
better than average but or scientific
results
right and so what you're saying is
science refers to the process
science is the scientific process
science is not the results of the
scientific process or the people doing
it or
well okay i want to fix that a little
bit okay you can't trust any given
result
right it requires that the experiment
was done well and you're almost never
going to be in a position to know
but over time good science
will drive out bad science good
conclusions will replace bad conclusions
and the
the idea the whole purpose of this
clumsy difficult endeavor that we call
science is to ultimately converge
on models of the universe that are so
highly predictive
that we can call them theories that they
become
the closest thing to a truth claim that
we can make
yep and so in any case
trusting in that process over very short
time scales
is bound to be dangerous trusting in
that process over
the long time scale is the best hope
we've got and so anyway trust science
i would say and if you hear somebody say
trust the science
you might mention that they're making a
little error
and probably don't make a friend doing
so well
engage in social distancing as you're
mentioning this that'll give you uh you
know a head start zone
yeah you'll have a head start yeah if
you need to flee
all right uh well we will finish with a
few announcements here
um we're gonna take a 15-minute break uh
for those of you listening on the
podcast we'll be back next week as usual
uh for those of you watching on youtube
we encourage you to take
take that break with us and then come
back with our live q a uh we'll be
answering questions that you've posed
during this super chat we prioritize
questions from the first super chat on a
monetary basis and in the second super
chat we answer them in the order in
which they come in in the second half of
the
live q a you can become a dark horse
member at my patreon
heather heing's patreon uh the private q
a
for next month we have a two hour
private q a as i mentioned at the top of
the
hour hour and a half whatever we are now
which is always the last sunday of the
month at 11 a.m pacific
is tomorrow the questions have already
been posed
for this month but um but it's it's
smaller we can pay attention to the chat
it's a lot of fun
we encourage you to join us you can also
at either of our patreons get access to
the discord server
which is a lively conversational miliew
at your patreon you have at a higher
price your point a couple of
conversations a month on the first
saturday and sunday yep so that's
next week we'll be having a conversation
on the
state and fate of the world and what we
might do about it that's uh the saturday
conversation
right before our live stream yeah sunday
uh we
talk evolution and anyway they're both
great conversations
uh there's some long-standing people in
it quite a number of new people and
anyway they're very very lively and fun
wonderful we do have stuff
for sale mugs t-shirts
stickers at
www.store.darkhorsepodcast.org
and there is a 10 sale all weekend by
blues all caps b-y-e-b-l-u-e-s
is the code so if you find that you
don't have enough stuff this is one way
to deal with it
which is yeah most of our problems yes
um
uh you can email our moderator
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com for any logistical questions
um like how do i post a question
um where was the store again what's the
code
and um yeah maybe that's it i guess you
know once again we want to thank
bill maher and his whole crew and um and
we'll be back
in about 15 minutes in the meantime
get outside yep thanks everybody we will
see you
shortly
all right
[Music]
you